okay so the Mandalorian season 3 episode
7 is now out and throughout this video
we're gonna be recapping the plot
breaking down all the Easter eggs and
also going over the characters so we get
teasers two in the century somehow heavy
spoilers has returned and with this
episode also clearly setting things up
coming in Ahsoka there's a lot to talk
about in it we of course also have the
finale next week so make sure you don't
miss a thing by subscribing to the
channel and also please smash that
Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the video
this is the way this is the way this is
the way anyway last week saw the person
we time traveled with in a man's
DeLorean getting taken down by Bow and
the Mandalorian
this was in an effort to get back to
Bozo crew which is where she had an ax
to grind over no longer being the leader
defeating Rove she was then presented
with the darksaber due to her
technically winning it in combat all the
way back in episode 2. that takes us
into this entry which sees the return on
moth Gideon and also the re-emergence of
The Shadow Council Gideon ends up
getting his own Mandalorian armor in the
century and you might remember that back
in our episode 5 breakdown that we
talked about a big clue towards this
oh shout out to Ryanair he played Ryan
Harry shut the up Ryan Airy but he
pointed out on his last breakdown that
they've added in a Mandalorian helmet to
the beginning of the Disney plus Star
Wars logo many people thought this might
be Mando but he pointing out that this
is shown in a red light and this denotes
that it's actually a villain I actually
think this might belong to moff Gideon
and Gideon might even end up in full
Mandalorian armor by the end of the
season which is a big
[Music]
so over the last seven weeks we got one
Theory time right
this was because of something ryanairy
said so I'm few men shut the
up Ryan Airy anyway we start off on
the planet Coruscant with a liar Kane
making her way through the streets
heavily inspired by Blade Runner we see
her long trench coat and the Tokyo
inspired City washed with the blue
filter and neon lights in the Blade
Runner story Earth was coming off the
back of World War III and poisonous
toxins had been released into the air
which destroyed the atmosphere this is
why it was always raining in L.A and why
the sun was almost completely absent in
the case of coruscan there's obviously
lots of traffic and skyscrapers and the
further down you go the darker it is
because there's less light able to
penetrate the vast blanket of cars in
buildings this is happening at night but
the lower levels of the city do tend to
be the more crime-infested ones it was
actually a canceled Boba Fett game
called 1313 which would take place on
that level of the city and show us all
the criminal dealings that we have going
on there Elias approached by a probe
Droid and she gives a TK number as her
identification TK was a designation
given to all Imperial Stormtroopers and
officers and this shows where her
allegiances lie now in the Dr Pershing
episode we did theorize that she was
punishing Pershing for betraying moth
Gideon in the second season he was the
one who told Mando and KOA Gideon's ship
was and the entire Ploy now seems like
it was to get revenge for selling him
out it's important to bear in mind that
she's really working as a triple agent
and though her loyalties lie with Gideon
she's also working for the Republic
pretending to be a spy for them so that
she can oust amnesty officers because
she betrayed Pershing I'm sticking with
the punishment angle but she may also be
fishing out people for Gideon who could
turn and Aid him now she's also been
keeping an eye on the dealings of what's
been going on with all this stuff this
side and she reports of things on
Navarro along with the Pirates revealing
that it was the mandalorians that helped
grief she also informs Gideon that the
two sworn enemies have teamed up now
this video is brought to you by
landscaped now April is actually
testicular cancer awareness month so we
thought we'd team up with them to raise
awareness and fundraise for a good cause
now did you know that one guy every hour
every day is diagnosed with testicular
cancer so this is a reminder to all men
out there check yourself manscaped in
addition to providing the right tools
and solutions for safe and easy
manscaping has partnered with the
testicular cancer society to spread
awareness for men's health and early
cancer detection so while you're down
there cleaning up your sack why not just
give it a little feel see if there's any
lumps changes or if you feel pain we can
save balls together now together to
remind guys to check for testicular
cancer for a limited time only you get
this amazing new manscape lawnmower 4.0
this is a special edition purple one
it's completely waterproof it's got that
4000k led technology so it can light up
your face as you're shaving there's only
10 000 units as well only ten thousand
of them and once it's gone it's gone
also with the launch of the special
edition a 4.0 manscape they're going to
be donating 50 000 yes fifty thousand
dollars to their longtime partner the
testicular cancer society to help those
impacted by testicular cancer get the
new lawnmower 4.0 TCS special edition
trimmer and help manscape raise
awareness and give back to the
testicular cancer society visit
manscape.com TCS to learn more about how
to check yourself while enjoying your
manscape products at home get 20 off in
free shipping with the code heavy
spoilers at checkout when you go to
manscape.com that's 20 off free shipping
and just go to manscape.com and enter
the code heavy spoilers I've left the
link in the description if you want to
head over there right now and get this
amazing purple trimmer donates to
charity and also just raises awareness
for testicular cancer thanks now the
episode itself is called the spies and
this two policies Mano getting captured
come the end of the entry after the
intro with a liar we cut him off Gideon
and semen along Corridor with doors that
we also saw in The Phantom Menace the
Stormtroopers designs here have been
slightly altered and we see that these
are slowly inching towards how they
looked with the first order ain't
nothing more menacing than the character
walking down a corridor with a cape and
we discovered that the reason he escaped
was because he supplied the Imperials
with beskar this is why Teva found the
metal signature in the shuttle and also
why they end up taking on the things
that they do costume wise throughout the
century The Moth would of course be
highly sought after as he led the attack
in the night of a thousand years that
wiped out millions of mandalorians he
was also a high-ranking ISB officer and
getting their hands at him meant that
they'd stop him from spilling Secrets
now originally the Republic won a
department trial for war crimes but the
Imperials getting him out has only
emboldened him further we then see him
walking through a laboratory and in
there we can catch cloning tanks with
figures inside now as we let alone
they're all part of the Imperials that
are partaking in an experiment called
project Necromancer somehow Palpatine
returns and I think that the series in
Ahsoka will be going over all the ins
and outs that got the story to where it
was in the rise of Skywalker we know
from the back and forth nature of the
trilogy that this was kind of attacked
on at the end with the original plan
being that snow could be the big bad and
that pulps was put into rise of
Skywalker late into the production where
this cloning was always part of the plan
it is another thing entirely as there
were rumors that Matt Smith was supposed
to be playing a younger version of the
character again that might not be the
case but they have at least went back
and tried to fill in the blanks between
the series and what's to come the tanks
that we saw back in season 2 episode 5
very much foreshadow this and the
version we see here is way closer to
being a human I'm guessing that they
created Palpatine first and then pulps
went on to great snoke and then used him
as a puppet I've no idea why I didn't
didn't just use himself because it would
look much more impressive if pulps was
back from the dead but after the
Empire's big failing maybe my man just
wanted to use his burner account to lead
the first order either way we are slowly
starting to see how the emperor came
back even if there are others that
wanted his position now this kind of
takes us into the shadow Council who we
see in hologram in the Next Room titled
the shadow Council because they worked
from the Shadows the first thing we hear
them talking about is how they can't
shiny signs of true strength as it might
tip off the Republic they refuse to even
meet with one another face to face and I
love how we have this hologram meeting
that keeps things secretive by having
them all in different locations in space
after the destruction of the second
death star many sides of it fractured
off into their own thing but the council
brought together all these different
sides in order to try and keep things
going scene is essential to keeping the
Imperials alive it basically forms
somewhat of a union between these sides
in which they could plot and plan away
but there were things inside of it that
caused this to fall apart I know it was
formed by gallius racks he planned to
eliminate the council at the Battle of
jakku this would leave just brendel
hooks alive as he saw him being an
essential element of how to salvage the
Empire now the first person that we see
is an unnamed bald Commander not shaming
the guy for having no hair yeah I'm
losing some of mine but his appearance
is actually important in the comics we
know that hux killed an imperial officer
and though I may be clutching at straws
I think this guy is him honestly I just
love the tone of this opening I know you
guys went hard on me for complaining
last week but the series has taken
things so seriously that I kind of
thought they messed up with the overall
feeling of the series yeah though I
think it's really gripping and there's
so much atmosphere early on that just
lets you know they're taking all these
things very seriously I'll stop going on
about last week I promise and the next
office that we see is Guild pallion
who's also a major character in the
expanded lore one of the high-ranking
generals of the Empire he's someone who
was enthralled with thrawn in several of
the side novels and stories making voice
appearance in Rebels I think that he
will probably become a big player on
Ahsoka due to thrawn being the big bad
of that captain of the naval Star
Destroyer harbringer he was initially a
member of the third Fleet however he
switched sides with thrawn once the
original Grand Admiral of that was
exposed as a traitor this was all to do
with project Stardust which as we
learned in Rogue one centered around the
creation of the Death Star palyan ended
up Johnny thrawn's seventh fleet and in
the cannon he notably helped run a
blockade on lothal in the legend
storyline he was second in commander
thrawn and it's possible that this is
how he'll be integrated into things
coming down the line they're very much
relishing in the new Republic's failings
and they know they have supporters out
there that will get behind them with a
re-emergence of thrawn now thrawn is
someone that everyone went wild for
after he was teased on the isoka episode
in season 2. we know that she's hunting
him and then he's gonna appear in live
action during her solo Series in August
played by Lars Mickelson he appeared on
stage at Star Wars celebration and an
image of him was dropped opt-in full
costume I did put this on my Instagram
account but it got taken down and the
whole thing's now being restricted so
I'd rather just avoid using it in this
video but it's everything you'd expect
blue skin red eyes and his white suit
now in the Canon he's appeared in both
the original legends lore and the Disney
reboot bringing his strategic mind stay
to the position of dominance throughout
the entire galaxy site as being the heir
to the Empire thrawn was very much
someone who was seen as being the next
deadline to take over things and I was
actually surprised that they ended up
going with snoke in the sequel Trilogy
instead of using him first heard of the
guy in the N64 Shadows of the Empire
game he's actually got a really
interesting backstory born on the planet
rental he traveled out of the unknown
regions of the Galaxy and after making a
name for himself in the chess Academy
known for his ruthless and strategic
mind he was able to think four steps
ahead of his enemies making him an
almost unbeatable opponent now upon
making his way out amongst the Stars he
ended up running into Anakin Skywalker
who he added didn't finding Padme
impressed with him Anakin ended up
bringing him before Palpatine who too
was enthroned when it came to meeting
him thrawn said that he thought
democracy was a waste of time and that
the only way to create order was to rule
through oppression he agreed to enlist
in the Royal Imperial Academy once
things changed anyone under become the
grand Admiral from this panani took over
the seventh fleet and along with a
shadow Council they kept the heart of
the Empire alive anyway they also
dropped a very important line and we see
that coming on hux is also amongst them
as you might have guessed he's actually
the father of Armitage hux played by
Donald Gleason in the sequel Trilogy
they did a great bit of casting here and
if you think the pal looks similar it's
because brendel's actually played by
domo's real life brother Brian the Hulk
started off as a junior officer in the
Grand Army of the Republic and he was a
character that greatly admired the ways
of the Jedi he saw them as Warriors who
took children from a young age and
trained them to become soldiers that
kept order throughout the Galaxy working
his way up the military he saw first
understand how ineffective Stormtroopers
could be and the Jedi had given him the
idea that children should be trained
from a young age he believed that
enlisting children from birth would not
only create loyalty to the Empire but
that it would also make it so they had a
lifetime of training to mull them into
the perfect combatant this is why we saw
in the likes of Finn how he'd been taken
when he was very young and it was
samyahine's Shadow Council constantly
try to put in place now this idea that
kids had to be a certain way is
something that's carried over to his
personal life too we know at one point
that he was married to a woman called
marital but the man was playing around
on the side and he ended up having
Armitage illegitimately with a kitchen
woman we have some it says kitchen women
in the wiki not my Frozen now we have
some flashbacks of how he treated hux Jr
in the comics and it's clear that he
viewed him as a disappointment brendel
was abusive towards him and this is
probably what spurred Armitage on to end
up the way that he did in the first
order we're kind of unsure about all the
ins and out stealings that brendel had
with the first order but we do know that
he oversaw the training program carried
out by Captain phasma by where deep down
she secretly hated him and along with
Armitage they can spider take him out
getting an untraceable poison she
injected brendel with a toxin and it
slowly started to kill him from the
inside out going to Medical droids for
help they found themselves unable to
treat him because of their lack of
knowledge concerning exactly what was
wrong with him he resigned himself to a
back to tank oh no back to them again
and this is where he withered into
nothing in the end he dissolved away in
it down to his atoms only leaving behind
some organs a tough to gray hair and a
couple of Bones Armitage helped the
southern seeds of Doubt with what
happened to him and he pushed the
narrative that brendell had traveled in
the further reaches of the Galaxy on an
exploration Mission whether this has
brought in a future part of the Disney
Plus show or not or remains to be seen
but we do know that he's working on
resurrecting the emperor titled project
Necromancer this is a cloning program
that will allow one to create duplicates
which can possess midichlorians and
their four-wheel the force this has been
the end game all along and it's why the
client was so desperate to get his hands
on grogu all the way back in the first
episode Dr Pershing of course wore the
cloners badge and if you've been keeping
up with the bad batch then you'll know
that cloning was a big part of that too
they are very much attempting to create
an heir to the Empire and also a thrawn
in the side of the Republic
anyway that's the main people in this
chamber and we discover that thrawn is
missing from the council kind of
guessing that he might show up next week
in a post-credit scene or something and
Gideon is kind of scoffing at the idea
that he's coming back we actually
thought that it would be revealed that
Gideon was working for him but he seems
to be doing the opposite and actually
trying to prop up new leadership
Necromancer is seen as the place for
that and though Gideon denies being
involved with it we know that he very
much is Guy of course held Pershing on
Navarro and hey what what's in that
what's in that back room there mate
let's let's have a look now Gideon wants
them to pull their efforts and share
their resources any request pratorian
gods and also tie interceptors and
bombers he of course was behind the
attack on Bo's home planet and with her
and Mando managing to take some out
they're having to restock now the
praetorian guards first showed up in the
Last Jedi when we look at things in
terms of release order they were one of
the good parts of that film
controversial and it led to the big
battle in the throne room after snoke's
death the praetorians themselves Were
Meant to build off the back of the
Imperial Royal Guards who we first saw
in Return of the Jedi these Crimson
armor wearing security forces were
Masters in several forms of martial arts
including Terrace Cassie which you'll
probably know from the PS1 game these
were often tasked with protecting
high-ranking individuals which is why
they were put in charge of guarding
snoke on his Flagship the supremacy they
actually have a long and Rich history in
our own world too and praetorian gods
were actually high-ranking members of
the Roman army tasked with protecting
Senators politicians and officials they
were highly trained bodyguards who
worked as security escorts for over
three centuries here they strike an
amazing figure and offer these
Mandalorian serial tests that ends up
leading to the death of a big character
who we'll talk about later on anyway
Gideon correctly guesses that the
mandalorians are trying to take back the
planet and thus they send the
reinforcements to him Gideon spins
around and it kind of makes me wonder
what this looked like as a hologram to
them because like they just seem from
one angle so is he spinning on the spot
or is the camera phone him I don't know
anyway from here we go to Navarro and
see that the ig11 statue has been fully
dismantled they are still recovering
from the pirate bombardment and things
seemingly get worse as the light Cruiser
comes over the city as we said last week
this belonged to moff Gideon but ax
wolves and Co to get back and they've
now put a mythosaurus symbol on the
bottom of it as we saw in episode 5 I
think the mandalorians have been given
this plot of land next to the lava flat
and they're very much making a home for
themselves initially they had to hide in
the sewers below the city but them now
being on the surface shows how much
things have changed Navarro has very
much been through the ringer in the
series but every time we visited it
seems to have gotten better and better
the kawakian monkey lizards were getting
spit roasted in season one not like that
and now they're living it up in the
trees at this point the Pirates have
been brought down and the Empire's also
been cleared out too which can allow it
to prosper even further I think that
this planet is very much the new
mandalorian's home and though they are
desperate to reclaim Mandalore with it
being a literal bomb site I think they
will Forge somewhere new here home is
where the heart is or some unless I
think they'll probably settle here
instead and that's the end of theory
time
him did too many last week so pretended
I wasn't going to do any this week but
we're back time time you sucker you fell
for you sucker you dick
anyway these Creeds are supposed to hate
one another and the masking doesn't go
down too well however bow is the one
that can unite them all as she has
walked both ways now wearing a night owl
and mythosaur Signet on her shoulders we
also see the armor once more and the
horns on her helmet are very symbolic as
we also get their return later on with
Gideon and his forces these horns were
put in place when Darth Maul took over
the death war too to get name dropped
later on in this entry they were put in
place to show that they were loyal to
him and it of course murdered the horns
that he had on his head here I think
it's meant to denote Imperial Alliance
but the armor having them could hint to
what's really going on with her if
you've been keeping up with our
breakdowns and then we theorize that she
might actually be revealed to be recast
and this being in place definitely seems
to cement that the shadow Collective
member was a devout follower of Darth
Maul and she even clashed against
bogatan at one point in the Clone Wars
her colors are the same and she also has
horns on her helmet like what Rook had
in the Clone Wars so that because of
this people have started to think that
they are the same person now the reason
that I'm bringing this up again is
because one of our subscribers Katie
Doyle sent me a great little clip from
the forge that might hint to this even
more in it if you look closely in the
water you actually get what looks like
it could be Darth Maul this Forge has
been known to reveal hidden things about
the past and it's of course also where
grogu saw my man Ahmed best he's back
baby I do think that if she was a
follower of more lat she is to trying to
find Redemption and that's very much
what this season has been about we had
Mando having to bathe in the Living
Waters by becoming a leader once more Dr
Pershing trying to move on from the past
and so on and so forth all of these have
tried to achieve something better and
though some have failed there's
definitely this theme laced in a lot of
the characters this could be carried
across to the armor too and obviously
let me know below if you agree with a
theory or not anyway grief arrives and
he brings with him the ig-11 sorry ig-12
mech suit that becomes grogu's armor in
the entry driven by manzella and he's of
course been working away on him since
episode 1 and have now wiped his memory
and dry drive to kill groku bad baby
it's a big swing that's definitely gonna
sell a lot of toys and it allows Kroger
to step it up a level and become closer
to your typical Mandalorian ig11 or
ig-12 is of course based off ig-88 who
was a bounty hunter that appeared
alongside Boba Fett E2 was a boss in the
shadows of the Empire which saw thrawn
introduced and as I've been saying it's
all connected now being repurposed means
that we can kind of get a sort of Jarvis
voiceover down the line with Taiko with
hiri potentially coming back to do that
I think when they're developing gragu's
voice they are kind of taking it easy
and testing the waters because they want
to get it right first time so that it
doesn't sound like an idiot thus
allowing ig-12 to answer questions it
gives them sort of an ability to
communicate but also doesn't mess things
up when he starts sounding like hello
it's me baby Kroger and they walk
through the streets and will you
subscribe yes yes yes they then go to a
vendor and get some mailerun fruit which
has shown up at many points in the Clone
Wars and bad batch anyway we could at
the campsite at night and bruh I guess
we know what happened to those two baby
birds
could be yet unintentionally made me
laugh out loud and even though I'm a
vegetarian yeah seen them get spit
roasted oh it's like dear me now there's
a feeling of an ease around the camp as
we have two different sects of competing
ideologies it's basically getting
political but Bo makes it clear that
they all have the same goal and need to
work together to take back the planet
she wants to scout the surface and go to
the great Forge which as we've learned
is very much the heart of their culture
you also get foreshadowing with the
mention of the bombings and nerthing
beasts that have laid dormant people
volunteer from both sides with it pretty
much being your main characters and a
couple of red shirts as well now the
fleet head out and upon arriving at
Mandalore we see the storms in the
atmosphere that ravage the planet gonna
point out a plot hole I'm hoping you can
explain but in this episode in episode 2
they make it pretty clear that your
content comes out of the storm so I
don't know how Gideon managed to hold
his 4K hologram meetings earlier unless
it's a different planet anyway we get a
drop ship moment that riffs on the
pirate one from before and see them
surveying all the wreckage below we also
see the Death Watch patch on one of
their arms and these were who rescued
Mando as a child Bo was also part of
them too and as we learned they kind of
fractured off into these smaller groups
the children of the watch later evolved
from them and it's nice seeing the
mandalorians all coming together anyway
they survey the wreckage and begin to
look for the forge your bow
address and Idols too and this is very
much the first mission of them all
working together now this point of barge
approaches with fins in sales similar to
jabbers these survivors remained on the
planet but they struggled to get off
world due to not having a ship capable
of space travel they asked for food and
this might be riffing on Treasure Island
in which bengan asked if the people he
came across had any cheese with them
this is actually also given another two
and Blade Runner 2049 when K comes
across Deckard though I might be tying
these old things together because it's a
big massive reach now they bring with
them stories about how they refuse to
surrender and thus were punished because
of it however Beau admitsachi did
actually surrender and this is how the
moth ended up with the lightsaber
mandalorians are of course supposed to
fight even in the face of death and it
clearly doesn't sit well with the rest
of the group this may cause further
conflict down the line as this action by
her of course led to millions of deaths
her sister satin was a pacifist too and
if they fail to retake the planet next
week then she may be seen as being the
wrong person in charge either way Mando
agrees to serve her by saying that he's
more bothered about honoring character
than he is about tradition in the dark
saber the survivors then agree to take
them to the great Forge shall we watch
as they sail out we see ax and Paz
playing chess with it showing how each
side has their own rules a love passes
vibrating blade and it seems like it was
ripped right out of June it leads to a
fight between the pair with this very
much being symbolic what Bo's gonna have
to deal with Mandalorian culture is
racked with Civil War and the planet
looks the way it does in part because
the centuries of infighting turn it into
this desert Kroger then breaks it up and
him being the feature of the planet is
summing I think we could see down the
line due to him actually handling the
situation and we watch the armor jet off
into space and Eric boss was saying on
Twitter how this was pretty convenient
the episode itself is called the spies
and it may even be revealed that she is
working with Gideon this will explain
the horns connection too and we may even
learn that the moth worked alongside
more at one point our edit the mat said
that Gideon might have actually
recruited the death watch in the past
and I think this would be a pretty big
reveal anyway as they sail out we see as
they're attacked by giant beasts that
destroys the barge and forces them to go
underground now this battle with the
Beast is something that's steeped in
Mandalorian culture I actually think
next week we'll likely have a showdown
with the mythosol and slowly we've been
building up these larger monsters and
creatures for the Mandos to fight off
against episode 2 had the mud beast and
season 2 had the crate dragon in its
first century at the start of this we
had the giant crocodile and then the
bird before we now get to this slowly
they are ramping up the size in scale I
think it's so that we can get used to
the idea that the characters will be
fighting bigger threats I'm sure there's
one I'm missing out that list of
monsters but you you get the point with
it now instead of the mythosol they
might actually end up fighting this and
who knows they might even use the
mythosaur to take it down anyway they
Rush underground and make it to the
great Borge at this point Troopers come
in and oh they fly out they fly now
they fly now it's possible that these
might even be Imperial super Commandos
that were Mandalorian Warriors loyal to
the Galactic Empire they did appear in
the Clone Wars war jet packs and fought
like what we see here so I might be
reaching but that could definitely be
the case anyway this leads to a big
battle against them in which some die
and others are chased underground we see
the subsurface has been transformed with
more Imperial looking tunnels dotted
throughout it the forge is very much a
place that you rebuild from and it's
clear that the Empire have started the
launch up from here feels like one of
the best action scenes in the show and
they stumble across some giant hangers
and armies of Gideon's forces now the
inside of this kind of reminded me a bit
of illum from falling order its
crystalline structure is extremely
memorable and it's also where Jedi would
travel to in order to build their
lightsabers now this is an important
place for them to potentially get due to
what we know about illum down the line
though this isn't fully confirmed when
you return to it later on in the game
you'll see that it's getting
Construction done on it that resembles
Starkiller base it's possible that when
Mandalore was transformed in this
glass-like structure that the imperial
saw a place they could build a weapon
like this then maybe after the planet
for that specific reason however we do
learn that Gideon has used it to create
an evolution of the dark trooper's suit
so maybe that's a sole intention now
though Mano uses his flamethrower
valiantly he's eventually caught up in
wires and Gideon arrives rocking his
brand new suit gonna make a sick action
figure gonna sell loads of Funko Pops
that and he reveals The Purge of
Mandalore will now be completed Mando
has brought the fleet to them and he
sends out the bombers that are obviously
gonna lead to a big space battle next
week spoilers for that and the moth then
demands the darksaber back but whereas
Beau once surrendered she refuses to now
she attempts to cut through the hangar
doors and this of course was something
we saw Qui-Gon doing during The Phantom
Menace this allows her and the rest to
escape but Paz stays behind so he can
buy the other's time he takes out all
the gods on the platform but the
praetorian guards arrive in new stylized
helmets similar to a Mandalorian Paz
bursts at his personal combat Shield
killed and these were part of the
mandalorian's armor that were built to
fight the Jedi they can actually block a
lightsaber but they don't stand up too
well when there's five people stabbing
you now paz's death obviously brings a
lot with it as he has his son that we
met in the season mandalorians are
famous for taking in fowlings and if one
of their tribe dies then it's on the
others to raise them I very much think
this will be the case with what happens
going forwards and his son will carry on
the vizsler name I don't think that they
introduce this child by accident and
they clearly wanted to let us know that
the name would be carried on for further
entries his famous ancestor tarvisler
brought the Manos and Jeddah together
and he also created the darksaber that
unites the entire people prevezla was
Bo's leader at one point and Paz of
course has been a big thing in the show
anyway we close out on his body any
entry on a tower note we don't know what
Bo's doing after this but I'm guessing
that she's going to help them be in
space and then potentially go and get
reinforcements from the other planets
I'm guessing that this means we could
see return of Boba Fett and potentially
TiVo and some of the rebels they'll
likely bring grief across too and I can
imagine that many people who featured in
the series will probably make a return
this idea of a meme captured of course
riffs on the fact that kragus captured
last season but why they just don't kill
the guy I'll never know Bo being the
lead in charge of getting him back also
shows the direction that the series is
going in too and that Star Wars
celebration the creative team made it
clear that the Mandalorian title was
used as a way to now talk about other
characters and they didn't want to just
keep the focus solely on din this Series
has definitely taken more focus on Beau
and there's even the possibility that
they might kill Mando off next week and
pass things over there hopefully I think
that's a long shot and I don't want to
get too much into the gossiping rumors
but there have been things floating
around for a while a Pedro might be
leaving soonish and thus they want to
keep the story going with other
characters that's definitely a
possibility too and I think it would be
difficult to just go back to episodes
about Mano and grow go off on adventures
in the Galaxy after mandalore's taken
back I think that they're also gonna
capitalize on the mythical thing without
potentially taking it down and being
fully anointed as the leader grogu for
me is where the real future lies though
and due to his lifespan I can seem being
a character that carries on the
Mandalorian Legacy for centuries likes
of Isla he's half Jedi half Mandalorian
and thus he could be the character down
the line that ends up leading them all
maybe Mando will reject living with them
but yeah lots of things that could
happen next week now we also likely see
things getting set up for the Ahsoka
series too I'm really sorry I haven't
done a full brightening of that trailer
as this Easter weekend has been kinda
hectic and I've been kind of putting my
family on the back burner recently to
work on video so I just wanted as much
free time with them as I could get still
oh they kept dropping trailers but yeah
unfortunately priorities they lay they
lay with some some other people who
dislike the video I don't give a
now the main thing to take from the
trailer is that thrawn is of course
returning and that we will happily be
tying in with elements of rebels they've
even made the final shot the series and
live action and Sabine inhera Chopper
and Ezra will also be coming over from
that there won't even possibly appears
in front of Mount tentus and they may be
leading with that in this show it's all
going down and I personally think that
the new look is brilliant I'm just
hoping they're tying it into Rebels so
much doesn't scare people off we don't
have any idea what's going on I do think
that Star Wars is kind of pulling from
the cartoons a bit too much and there's
a lot of my Nomi mates who've stopped
watching because they have no idea who
these people are I think when we look
back at some of the fan favorites from
this series they were created and
introduced for this series and yeah I
think personally just sticking with them
might have been the better way to go
about it now as are my thoughts on this
entry I really really enjoyed it and I
think it's up there as being one of the
best Mandalorian episodes when they take
things seriously like this you know they
give us drama tension explore history
and culture of the mandalorians I really
get invested and hopefully we see more
of this in the finale next week I'm sure
we will because this feels like it's a
two-parter and with it being from the
same director it seems like it's gonna
be good everything kind of evolved at
this point with this getting muff Gideon
wearing that the introduction of the
Shadow cancel and it just sets up so
many things that they can capitalize on
next week obviously we'll see and that
closes out the latest entry so let me
know your thoughts on it in the comments
below also I love the year predictions
for next week if you think they've got
enough time to really deliver on this
season so yeah just comment below and uh
let your boy know now we are in
competition right now and giving away
the Superman 4K box set to 3 subscribers
on the 15th and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
repeat the comments at random on the
15th and the winners are the last one
are on the screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want smells to watch
we've got a breakdown on screen right
now might be the Marvel's trailer and we
are working on a bigger breakdown of
that at the moment but yeah that's gonna
be hopefully coming out later on today
so keep an eye out for that and yeah
I'll see you over that video or
whatever's on screen right now you take
care yourself peace